[Música]
Hola Yo soy Natalia Cabrera parada y les
doy la bienvenida aquí a América este es
el magacín de France 24 para revisar en
profundidad las noticias y las historias
de nuestro continente y esto es lo que
veremos hoy
la fórmula vicepresidencial de Donald
Trump Mike pence le lanzó un desafío y
anunció que va a competir con él por la
candidatura republicana de la
presidencia de Estados Unidos de Cara a
las elecciones de 2024 se sumacía una
concurrida contienda por la nominación
que tendrá que ser definida en las
primarias
el presidente de Colombia Gustavo Petro
denunció que hay un golpe blando en su
contra luego de que se conocieran unos
audios del ex embajador en Venezuela
Armando Benedetti en los que dice entre
otras frases que si se divulga de dónde
salió el dinero de la campaña se van
presos todos el partido del mandatario
negó haber recibido aportes del político
de larga Data y en Venezuela
recientemente se reanudaron los
trasplantes de donante vivo después de
haber estado suspendidos por la escasez
de inmunosupresores la situación es
crítica para el 90% de los pacientes que
necesitan un órgano denuncian que están
condenados a morir
Y empezamos hablando de la carrera de la
Casa Blanca falta un año y medio para
las elecciones presidenciales en Estados
Unidos pero el campo de batalla comienza
a establecerse y a diferencia de la
guerra en la política los bandos se
mueven de amigos a enemigos el ex
vicepresidente Mike pence le lanzó un
desafío a Donald Trump con quien llegó
al Cargo en 2016 y anunció su intención
de ser el aspirante republicano para
enfrentarse a Joe biden en los comicios
previstos para noviembre de 2024 así lo
anunciaba
como he dicho muchas veces en ese
fatídico día las palabras del presidente
Trump fueron imprudentes y pusieron en
peligro a mi familia y a todos en el
Capitolio pero el pueblo estadounidense
merece saber que ese día el presidente
Trump también me exigió elegir entre él
y la Constitución
creo que cualquiera que se ponga por
encima de la Constitución nunca Debería
ser presidente de Estados Unidos y
cualquiera que le pida a otra persona
que lo ponga por encima de la
Constitución nunca debería volver a ser
presidente de Estados Unidos
pero no es el único esta semana dos
pesos pesados entraron en la Competencia
por la candidatura republicana el ex
vicepresidente Mike pence y el
exgobernador de Nueva Jersey Chris
Christi junto a ellos son al menos ocho
personas las que quieren arrebatarle la
nominación al expresidente Donald Trump
entre los aspirantes Está también el
gobernador de Florida ron de santis y el
ex y la ex embajadora de Estados Unidos
ante la ONU Nicky hayley
la semana de Trump fue complicada además
por sus problemas legales se convirtió
en el primer ex presidente de la
historia de la Unión Americana en ser
imputado con cargos federales tras el
hallazgo de documentos clasificados en
su residencia de Mara lago son 37 cargos
por el manejo de los archivos que
incluyen obstrucción a la justicia y
conspiración dos de sus abogados
renunciaron él asegura que se trata de
una cacería de brujas precisamente para
impedirle participar pero recordemos que
esto no impediría que sea candidato
según la Constitución estadounidense
Y regresamos al tema de las elecciones
por el lado demócrata aunque se da por
hecho que será el presidente Joe biden
el candidato dos personas le han lanzado
El desafío Robert Efe Kennedy Jr sobrino
del ex presidente y la escritora marrian
williamson
y nos vamos a Colombia el presidente
Gustavo Petro mostró en las calles que
no está solo en medio de la crisis
política que enfrenta tras destituir a
dos funcionarios clave para su Victoria
en las urnas en 2022 en medio de un
escándalo de escuchas ilegales y
señalamientos por la presunta
financiación ilegal de su campaña Petro
pidió al congreso seguir adelante con
sus reformas con las que busca disminuir
la desigualdad social en la nación
Sudamericana veamos el informe que
preparamos para ustedes
un baño de masas en medio de una
profunda crisis el presidente de
Colombia Gustavo Petro reunió en las
calles de Bogotá a sus seguidores
mientras señala que hay un golpe blando
en su contra en curso
usamos magistrados no chuzamos
periodistas no chozamos gente de la
oposición no violamos los derechos de la
humanidad en el territorio colombiano
no
encontraron no encontra un solo indicio
pueden allanar el Palacio pueden allanar
si quieren el ejército la policía actual
y no encontrarán
una sola evidencia de eso estoy
absolutamente seguro de que seamos Un
gobierno violador de los Derechos el
presidente colombiano está contra las
cuerdas luego de que un medio de
comunicación local filtrara unos audios
del ex embajador en Venezuela Armando
Benedetti en los que afirmaba enojado
por la falta de protagonismo en el
gabinete que se hablaba de cómo se había
financiado la campaña de Petro a la
presidencia en 2022 se hundían todos el
partido de Petro la Colombia humana negó
haber recibido aportes económicos de
Benedetti carecen de verdad Y son
infundados los señalamientos de
supuestos recursos que habría gestionado
el señor Benedetti para financiar la
campaña presidencial del Doctor Gustavo
Petro sin embargo el respaldo de Armando
Benedetti que ha tenido múltiples
afiliaciones políticas pasando por el
uribismo de derecha hasta la izquierda
con Petro fue clave para la victoria del
actual presidente el también
excongresista dice que los audios fueron
manipulados y pidió Perdón al mandatario
hoy sin haber cumplido un año en el
poder el gabinete multipartidista de
Petro fue desarticulado y la coalición
en el congreso que iba a sacar adelante
sus reformas está debilitada mientras la
popularidad del mandatario se desplomó
al
26%, pero el apoyo que Petro ha perdido
en su país llega del extranjero más de
370 intelectuales políticos y líderes
sindicales del mundo desde
Baltazar garzón publicaron una carta en
la que le dan su respaldo en el íbamos a
quedarnos allí en Bogotá donde miles de
familias viven del reciclaje de las
basuras en la calle son los más pobres
de la ciudad los relegados los
recicladores son la evidencia de la
miseria y la falta de oportunidades en
Bogotá en el país muy pocos hogares
separan las basuras son sus manos las
que están más abajo en la escala social
las que se encargan es un trabajo
crucial en esta ciudad de 8 millones de
habitantes el informe es de Julia corto
a Juan Orozco y Pascal mariani
de noche y de día se pasean por las
calles de Bogotá en búsqueda de cartón
plástico y vidrio
es un turno a la semana que yo digo
bueno va a trazar un día hasta el otro
día entende y pues en ese tour no tengo
que echar yo abrigada que me compense lo
de casi tres turnos para yo descansar en
la capital colombiana estos hombres que
arrastran carretas llenas de cosas hacen
parte del paisaje urbano como Damián hay
más de 25.000 recicladores calificando
la basura en las calles el número no
deja de aumentar a pesar de lo duro del
trabajo trabajo de ayer de 300 a 350
kilos 350 kilos aproximadamente según
él con todo No porque no todo es
material ahí llevo agua y llevo ropa
para cambiarme el trabajo Estos
trabajadores del reciclaje suelen
habitar en la calle muchos son
inmigrantes de la vecina Venezuela su
trabajo muy precario es sin embargo
fundamental para la clasificación de la
basura en Bogotá
en promedio ganan entre 2 y 4 dólares al
día Apenas lo suficiente para subsistir
y permitirse una habitación día a día
Damián hizo una buena recolección
46.500 pesitos eso es el equivalente a
11 dólares con los pesos en el bolsillo
se va a descansar antes de la próxima
jornada desde 2003 los recicladores
cuentan con un estatuto protegido por la
corte constitucional es deber del Estado
defender sus derechos y aplicar medidas
para protegerlos pero las políticas
públicas no han continuado más o menos
el 70% del material que tenemos nosotros
acá y que ponemos nuevamente en
recirculación depende de los recitadores
de a pie para otros el auge del
reciclaje ha sido una oportunidad he
aquí uno de los últimos pasos Antes de
que los materiales sean transformados
industrialmente pensamos como una
chatarrería de barrio
entonces hemos venido en la transición
de ir creciendo gracias a la industria y
a todo lo que lo que ha pasado en
Colombia con el reciclaje que ha crecido
mucho el reciclado en Colombia ya no es
pequeño junto a Montevideo y México
Bogotá es una de las ciudades
latinoamericanas más avanzadas en este
campo pero aún queda mucho camino por
recorrer en Colombia solo se recicla el
17% de los residuos
visitamos la vecina Venezuela ahora
donde desde hace seis años el gobierno
suspendió el programa de donación de
órganos de fallecidos por la
imposibilidad de garantizar los
inmunosupresores necesarios para
garantizar el éxito de la cirugía
recientemente se reanudaron solo los
trasplantes de donante vivo pero muy
pocos se han hecho en el sector público
y Los costos en el sector privado son
inaccesibles para la mayoría de los
venezolanos la situación es crítica para
el 90% de los pacientes nos lo cuenta la
corresponsal de France 24 en Caracas
Daniela Zambrano
Libia reina sufre de insuficiencia renal
y desde hace 11 años se conecta tres
veces por semana una máquina de diálisis
en 2017 su hermano iba a donarle un
riñón pero el gobierno suspendió los
trasplantes en ese tiempo ha visto morir
a una gran cantidad de pacientes la
mayoría han fallecido a la espera de un
trasplante con la esperanza mucho de
que los trasplantaran pero nada
actualmente en Venezuela y cerca de
siete mil pacientes en diálisis
esperando mejorar su calidad de vida y
según la ong prepara familia Al menos 75
niños con enfermedades crónicas ha
muerto desde la suspensión de los
trasplantes tenemos seis años de
paralización del sistema desde la
organización Nacional de trasplante de
Venezuela la doctora Anabel arminio
expone la gravedad de la situación
evidentemente si los pacientes no se
trasplantan que es una vía de salir de
diálisis la otra vía nada que es morirse
ahora En qué tiempo se van a morir si
tenemos que esperar que sea en muy largo
plazo para porque habremos hecho las
cosas bien porque si se mueren en muy
corto tiempo también las estamos
haciendo mal en diálisis
el estado tampoco garantiza con
regularidad los inmunos opresores
necesarios para los pacientes ya
trasplantados Marlín rojas madre de una
niña trasplantada denuncia que la
entrega de los medicamentos por parte
del seguro social no es constante y en
algunas ocasiones están vencidos
cuando no se toma el inmunosupresor
viene el rechazo y el rechazo este es
prácticamente un paso para la muerte
un trasplante durante vivo en una
clínica privada puede costar entre
70.000 y 100 mil dólares o más un monto
inaccesible para la mayoría de los
pacientes mientras el estado no reanuda
el sistema de Procura de órganos de
cadáver y no aumente la frecuencia de
trasplantes de órgano vivo en el sector
público Son miles los que como Libia
están condenados a pasar el resto de su
vida atados a una máquina viendo como a
diario su salud se deteriora y me
despido en Nueva York hasta donde llegó
el humo de los incendios que consumen
Canadá las nubes de humo generaron que
se cancelaran los vuelos y se
suspendieran muchos servicios no
esenciales en varias ciudades del
noreste de Estados Unidos las
autoridades alertaron que el humo podría
generar problemas respiratorios gracias
por acompañarme en esta emisión de aquí
América en la producción estuvo Lorena
Pérez Sigan viendo France 24 y France
24.com
[Música]